Everybody!
Calm down!
I'm so sorry!
We took so long!
Guys!
I'm sorry everyone!
I know you guys waited for so long!
For 40 minutes!
I'm so sorry!
Look!
Look everybody!
I know, I know!
There was a lot more work than I thought when I did this... to do this karaoke.
I was like... I had so many ideas!
There was so many ideas in my head!
It was crazy!
And then I like... last minute I was like... wait!
I have more ideas!
And then... guys!
Calm down!
Guys!
I know!
You've been waiting for 40 minutes!
Some of you guys haven't even...
I've been like... fucking standing there for 40 minutes already!
And we haven't even started!
But then I had more ideas!
And then I had to add stuff last minute to the set!
And then... oh my god!
I'm so nervous!
I really am!
But we should... we should really... you know... we should... guys!
Camera!
Close up camera!
Come back!
Come closer!
How are you gonna see me up there?
You know?
How are you gonna see me like this?
Alright!
Hello everybody!
Alright guys!
Okay!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
You guys had to wait that...
You guys had to wait so long!
I'm so sorry!
I... you know... I thought like... don't worry!
I have everything I need to do!
But then like... suddenly my mind was like... but like... wait!
There's more things I wanna do though!
And then... and then I had like... there's some fucking crazy ideas that I got some people to help out for us too!
So like... I'm... okay!
By the way!
Before you... for those who are new here who've never heard me sing...
I need to tell you guys like... I'm not a singer!
By no means am I a singer!
I like... basically make up for it with like... with making it like a show!
Because... although I can't sing... at least you'll have fun listening!
Like... not fun listening to my voice but like... with the visuals!
You know?
At least the visuals will be...
you know?
It will be nice!
I like to say I am... I am a... the type of singer that you will not see me at karaoke because that's how embarrassed I am...
To my... at my own singing.
But!
I did promise you guys a karaoke as a charity reward.
So here... here I am!
I am... I am very, very, very, very, very nervous right now!
It's been a very long time since... I guess you can say I sing with soul.
You know?
You don't come to me to hear good singing.
You come to me to... I guess to laugh at my singing I guess.
Anyway... um...
I'm gonna spoil the first song because I have to wear a little something for this song.
And also I need to... I need soundcheck guys to be here to check out the volume of this as well.
So if... soundcheck guy are you here?
Are you here soundcheck guy?
Let me see... is... is soundcheck guy here?
We need... I need to be sure that the... the sound is okay.
Alright... okay... we're gonna spoil... we're gonna spoil the... the first song chat.
Just cause I need to know if you guys could hear it.
It will be spoiled by the first song chat.
Is this okay?
Alright so you sort of know what song this is now.
This is a... this is a Doki Bird classic.
Cause this is the only... this is like one of the... the five songs I'm like super confident in.
Alright...
Let me... let me...
Put on something as well.
Alright...
I'm gonna...
Alright it's pretty quiet.
Let me bring it up.
Alright thank you soundcheck guy.
I'm glad we had soundcheck guy here to help us out.
But anyway let's just... let's put us...
Put our little costume on real quick.
Let's put it...
And...
Since we know what song this is.
Alright is this better?
Is this better soundcheck guy?
Is this better?
I like... I'm like just like...
Fucking edging with like...
With not even singing this.
I'm back now guy.
Okay I'm back now.
That was so funny because it was like...
What do you mean?
It's YouTube cause I...
My OBS is still up.
And then like... and then it crashed the moment I...
Like I typed that.
Anyway let's do this again.
Is this song okay?
Is it okay now?
Is it okay?
That was awkward.
I like how...
I like how fucking...
Uh...
It's still pretty quiet.
Okay I'll push it up.
Alright.
Oh it's cause like...
Oh it's cause it reset itself.
It's cause it reset itself when my OBS crashed.
Alright we're back.
Ba da ba ba da da da.
Ba ba ba da da da.
Ba ba dum ba ba da da dum.
Ba dum ba ba da da dum.
Ba dum ba ba da... Is it better now?
Ba dum ba da da da dum.
I like how we're just good here.
Alright!
This is it.
Finally!
Sorry everybody!
We can fucking...
We can finally sing!
Alright are you guys ready?
Alright we're back.
We're so back.
I hear you.
Oh, that's mean.
No one's saying be there.
No one's saying stop that.
No one's saying see here.
Free to run around all day.
Free to do it all my way.
Yeah!
I'm the king!
Kings don't need advice from little hornbills for a start.
If this is where the monarchy is headed, come here!
What?
Out of service, out of our hands.
Why wouldn't you hand about?
This child is getting wildly out of way.
That's me!
Oh, I just can't wait to be king!
Everybody look left.
Everybody look right.
And where you look, I'm...
Satisfactlight!
Huh?
There's everything to go for broken sea.
Let's hear it if
we can see the finest thing.
Oh, I just can't wait to be king!
Woo!
That's me!
I'm the king!
I went with the...
The... The... The safest choice for the first song because, uh...
I know that...
This was a song I sang a lot as a little... As a little bird.
So, like, that's why I decided to go with, like, the safest choice.
That's the first song.
Because I know that, like, um... I say... I know the song, like, really, really, really, really well because I've listened to the song on repeat ever since I was little.
So I was like, alright, this is... This is gonna be the first song I'll sing then because I... I... I know this.
I mean, it's a good... It's a... It's a good warm-up song because it's like, oh, man, out of every song, I know this one is the one that, like, I have, like, the most confidence in.
So, yeah.
The very first song.
Um...
But, yes, if you guys... I don't know.
Never heard of Disney before.
The very first song I sang was...
I just...
Can't...
Wait...
To be...
King...
From Lion King.
Where's my little...
There it is.
This is my set list.
The very first song I sang.
I just can't wait to be king.
Yes, there is gonna be a lot... I'm gonna warn you guys right now.
There's gonna be a lot of... of Disney songs because, like, uh, Disney songs is, like, the songs I'm most confident in when it comes to singing.
Uh, so that's why...
I decided...
It's majority Disney.
Uh...
Majority of the stuff in here is... is Disney.
So, just... just a little warning.
Um...
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to grab my set list right now.
I think I realize what's causing the... the crashing a little bit.
And it's because of...
Uh...
I use... uh...
I use KaraFun for, like, my karaoke stuff.
And it's so fucking... I guess it overloads... overloads...
It overloads my Discord for some fucking reason.
Which doesn't make much sense because I'm like, why does KaraFun overload my Discord?
So I'm just gonna grab my set list off of...
Because I wrote my set list off of Discord.
So I'm gonna grab my set list and put it somewhere else so I know where it is.
So I know which to go next.
Okay, let me...
Let me make sure I can...
Let me post this somewhere so...
So I can look at my set list.
Until I solve this whenever.
Because like...
It's awkward because like...
I was like, what do I sing next?
I already forgot what to sing next!
I'm so nervous!
I'm so nervous right now!
And I'm forgetting things at the moment!
OH!
Okay, I remember now.
Guys, this one.
This one is also a classic that I like, too.
Uh, let me...
Alright, you guys might know...
What it is...
Judging from...
What I'm wearing...
Soon.
Very soon.
Uh...
Okay, now you know what it is.
Okay...
If you guys can recognize the first two notes of that song, you might know what it is.
This is also a classic that I don't sing this as often, but I do like it very very much.
I'm following my destiny.
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I possibly be?
Something of principle in nature.
That almost every creature knows.
Called survival of the fittest.
And checkin' is how it goes.
The animal that wins is gonna scratch and fight and claw and fight and punch.
And the animal that doesn't, well the animal that doesn't, well that...
Someone else.
Nudge nudge nudge nudge nudge...
I'm just saying how bad can I be?
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
I'm just following my destiny.
I'm just doing what comes naturally.
How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
It's a principle in business.
That everybody knows the sound.
This is the people with the money!
Make this everworld go around!
So I'm figuring my companies, I'm figuring my factory, I'm figuring my corporate sign!
Everybody out there, you take care of yours and me.
I'll take care of mine, mine, mine, mine, mine!
Let me hear you say, smogulent smoke!
Slippily stop!
Complain all you want, it's never ever ever gonna stop!
Come on!
How bad can I possibly be?
I'm just building economy.
How bad can I be?
Just look at me paying this puppy!
Come on!
How bad can I be?
How bad can I possibly be?
Let's see...
All the customers are buying!
And the money's multiplying!
And the PR people are lying!
And the lawyers are denying!
Who cares if a few trees are dying?
This is all so gratifying!
How bad...
How bad can this possibly be?
Haha!
Alright, my time's up!
I'm a good person!
Haha!
Hehehe!
Oh yeah, I think I'm a pretty good person guys!
Hahaha!
Hehehe!
Anyway, that was how bad can I be?
from Mr. Ed Helms himself.
One of the OG Tumblr boys out there.
What capitalism does to a tomato.
Shout out to the Onceler.
The OG Tumblr boy.
Let me take these off.
How bad can I possibly be?
A lot of these songs I chose are like super in my vocal range.
Or like I forced it to be in my vocal range.
Because I have a very, very small vocal range.
So just letting you guys know.
I'm not even going to write numbers right now.
I'm too lazy.
It's like 1.
I just can't wait to be king.
2.
How bad can I possibly be?
Not even 2.
How bad can I be?
But yes.
I hope your ears are okay chat.
I know that...
You know...
I'm not a singer.
So I hope everybody's ears are okay so far.
And no one is...
No one is dying at the moment.
But it's true.
As YouTube keeps dying...
Everybody's against me.
Oh my God.
I can't believe YouTube's dying.
They know.
They're like...
Doki has a karaoke.
Doki has a karaoke today.
So like...
We're gonna f*** with her.
They're like...
Well...
We're gonna fuck with her!
They're trying to silence the Tumblr sexy man agenda.
They know!
OBS knows I had a karaoke... YouTube knows I had a karaoke today!
They're trying to silence me!
Anyway guys, the next song is also a classic.
I have something special too for the next song.
It's one of the reasons why this took a while to prep for.
I'm gonna fumble with this because I didn't get to practice this as much as I would like to.
So I'm gonna fumble this song.
Well to be fair, when I said I didn't practice this much, I definitely didn't practice a lot for this one.
But I really really wanted to do it.
You're gonna realize what song this is the moment I swap the scenes.
You're gonna realize what song this is.
Chat, are you guys ready?
Okay, I don't know if you guys can hear the video though.
So let me know if you guys actually hear the video.
Do you guys actually hear this?
You guys can't?
Okay.
Okay, I thought you guys can.
Okay, I need to try to find...
Alright, there we go.
Do you guys see?
You guys can't hear the song?
Okay, thank God.
Good.
Because that song is my guide.
That's good.
Cause that song is my guide for this.
Okay, so there's a reason why this took so long.
Welcome to the Dragoon PTA meeting.
I have a...
I have a very, very, very important news to tell all of you.
The reason why I summoned all of you guys is that there is something very fucking important that I need to address right now and it's about the children.
it's about the children.
I need you guys to know, this is very important to me.
Because this is about the kids.
And we need to do something about it, okay?
I summoned all of you here because...
I feel like we have to...
There is something really bad going around.
That's affecting all our children and dragoons.
And that is why I am here today to summon...
I summoned all of you here today for this very important dragoon PTA meeting.
As you guys see, I have a DokiBirds plan of action.
I need to make sure I sync this video up correctly so it works.
So give me a second to sync this video up.
Okay.
I need to make sure this video is synced up.
Alright, let's see.
I hope this is synced up.
I'm not sure yet.
Alright, we're gonna try our best.
We're gonna try our best.
Times have changed.
Our kids are getting worse.
They won't obey their parents.
They just want to fight and curse.
Should we blame the government?
AHHHHH NO!
It's not synced up guys!
Oh my god!
My OBS disconnected!
I can't believe it!
I saw my OBS disconnected and I was like, bro...
This is... everything's against me.
YouTube's actually trolling me.
YouTube's actually trolling me today.
I can't believe it!
YouTube!
I worked so hard on this!
Why today?
I can't believe it.
YouTube's actually trolling me right now.
Alright, here we go.
We'll try again.
We'll try again guys.
This time.
YouTube, please let me finish this song.
This is Katniss' fault.
This is fucking Katniss' fault.
This is actually Katniss' fault.
We'll try again.
Alright, here we go.
Times have changed!
Our kids are getting worse!
They won't obey their parents!
They just want to fart and curse!
Should we blame the government?
Or blame society?
Or should we blame the Queen of the City?
NO!
Blame Canada!
With all their beady little eyes, their flopping heads, and playful eyes.
We need to form a full assault!
It's Katniss' fault!
Don't blame me for my sun dragoon!
He saw the darn cartoon, and now he's off to join the clan!
And my boy Eric once, had a picture on his shelf!
But now I see him tell me to fuck myself!
Well, blame Canada!
Blame Canada!
It seems that everything's gone wrong Since Katniss came along!
Not even a real country anyway.
My son could have been a doctor or a lawyer rich and true.
Instead he burned up like a piggy on a barbecue.
Should we blame the matches?
Should we blame the fire?
Or the doctors who allow him to inspire?
Heck no!
Blame Canada!
With all their hocky holler boo and that bitch dokey bird too.
Shame on Canada!
The smut we must cut, the trash we must smash.
The laughter and fun must all be undone.
We must blame them and cause the fuss before someone thinks of blaming us!
Yes.
There you go.
Anyway, thank you YouTube for letting me sing this song.
YouTube, thank you for letting me get through this video so I could sing this song, YouTube.
Huge shout out to one of my editors, Shad, for doing this.
Literally, he sent me this like 10 minutes ago.
I had this idea like... well, I had several ideas.
But this one, I had this idea like in the morning.
And I was like, Shad, can you do this?
And then they were like, I can try.
And then they actually sent this to me like 10 minutes ago.
And...
A huge, huge shout out to them for this.
I had this set up thing made in advance.
And I was like, don't worry.
I won't be singing Blame Canada until later.
So like... so send it to me whenever it's done.
So anyway, for those who don't know.
This was Blame Canada from South Park.
Thank you for coming to my Dragoon PTA meeting.
I really appreciate it.
And I just want to say like this is all Katniss' fault.
That the karaoke has been like crashing this much.
And I'm really sorry.
I'm not sorry because this is Katniss' fault.
So fuck you, Canada, for crashing my PC.
For crashing my YouTube, my OBS, and my PC.
Look, I worked so hard on this karaoke.
Fucking Canada, man.
Anyway, it's time to go back to the...
Alright, anyway, meeting's adjourned.
Meeting's adjourned.
Back to the concert hall.
Well, back to the concert hall.
Hey.
I'm back.
Anyway, guys.
That song was...
Blame Canada.
From South Park.
Alright, this next one.
This one I've been wanting to sing for a very, very...
Very, very, very, very, very long time.
I never ever had a chance to sing this song.
Because it's sort of...
It's not really obscure.
It's more like internet stuff.
It's like...
It's sort of like if you were on the internet when this came out.
Like it was everywhere.
And like it was...
It's based off of a...
It's like a...
A mini project starring a lot of like really big celebrities back then.
But it was like a fucking passion project.
And...
But like...
It was like...
You know...
It didn't really have like actual music rights.
Or anything.
So I never had a chance to really sing this song.
And this is like a song I really...
I really, really wanted to sing for a while now.
Anyway, so...
I think...
The best way to do this is if I...
Is if I...
Got the spotlight on...
Put this on.
And you'll realize why.
You'll realize why I put the spotlight on for this song.
Alright...
Look at these people amazing how sheep will show up for the slaughter.
No one's condemning you line up like lemons you'll lead to the water.
Why can't they see what I see?
Why can't they hear the lies?
Maybe the fee's too pricey for them to realize Your disguise is slipping I think you're slipping Now that your savior is still as a grave, you're beginning to fear me Like caveman fear thunder, I still have to wonder, can you really hear me?
I bring you pain, the kind you can't suffer quietly Fire up your brain, remind you inside you're wrining Society is slipping Hey guys...
Oh my god...
Okay, I downloaded the program.
Maybe...
This will be better.
Oh my god...
Guys, I can't believe it.
Are you guys ready for round two?
Are you guys ready?
Oh my god...
The stream slipped.
Okay.
Are you guys ready for round two, chat?
I'm ready for round two.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
It really is slipping.
It really is.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go again.
Stop it, Canada, please.
Alright, let's see if this works.
Is the volume okay for this?
So I use the program right now.
I'm using a program this time.
Alright, here we go.
Take two.
Anyway...
Look at these people.
Amazing how sheep will show up for the slaughter.
No one's condemning you.
Line up like lemons.
You lead to the water.
Why can't they see what I see?
Why can't they hear the lies?
Maybe the fee's too pricey for them to realize.
Your disguise is slipping.
I think you're slipping.
Now that your savior is still as a grave, you're beginning to fear me.
Like caveman fear thunder, I still have to wonder, can you really hear me?
I bring you pain, the kind you can't suffer quietly.
I up your brain, remind you inside your writing, society is slipping.
Everything's slipping away.
So...
Go ahead, right away, say it was horrible.
Spread the word, tell a friend, tell them the tale.
Get a pet, do a bug, heroes are over with.
Look at him, not a word, hammer me, nail.
Then I win, then I get everything I ever.
All the cash, all the fame, and so, so change.
Anarchy, better run, it's Dr. Horrible's turn.
You people all have to learn.
This world is going to burn.
Burn.
Uh, yeah, it's two R's.
H-O-R-R, yeah, right.
Burn.
No sign of any good, I won't give any, not to have surcing.
It's gonna be bloody, head up, Billy, buddy, there's no time for mercy.
Here goes no mercy.
And then I get punched.
Oh my god, maybe that was the way, I just need to...
Alright, guys, let's all expect to crash every two...
Guys, I'm gonna say it now, this is gonna be unarchived.
This is what just...
I'm sorry.
This is...
Way too fucking scuffed, this is gonna be unarchived.
We're crashing too much, we're crashing way too much.
Maybe whenever I get a new PC, we're going to...
We'll have another karaoke and bring back the...
At least you guys are lucky, you've made it, though.
You've made it.
Anyway, for those who don't know what that song is, it is Dr. Horrible's sing-along blog.
It's called Slipping.
And Dr. Horrible's sing-along blog was one of my favorite animated series for...
It wasn't a series, no, it was an anime movie.
It was a small animated movie project that was a passion project.
It had almost no budget.
But a lot of people were really...
It became a cult hit, basically.
It was a cult hit.
And it started Neil Patrick Harris and then the other people...
I don't remember the other...
Sorry, not animated, sorry.
Not animated, live action.
I mean, fucking what do you mean live action?
It was just a mini movie project.
And honestly, I loved every song.
I still love, by the way, I still love every fucking song that was in that album.
And there was like...
I think like Freeze Ray honestly was...
Oh yeah, Felicia Day.
Yeah, Felicia Day was in it.
Freeze Ray is one of my favorite...
Freeze Day...
Freeze Ray is one of my favorite songs in that movie.
But I know I can't sing Freeze Ray because Freeze Ray is mostly singing.
And I was like, nope.
It was...
I was like, nope.
I can't sing Freeze Ray.
So like I'll just do Slipping.
Because Slipping is also one of my favorite songs.
And Brand New Day too.
Almost every song in there is like...
Like, never mind, not almost.
All the songs in Dr. Horrible's sing-along blog is so fucking good.
And I'm so happy to do Slipping.
It's one of the songs I've always wanted to sing.
So I'm glad I was actually able to sing it here today for you guys.
I'm sorry for the scuff.
I didn't realize fucking...
It never happened before.
Like all these crashes on Karaoke Day.
They knew!
YouTube and OBS knew!
Okay, guys.
Alright.
Spoiler.
I'm actually getting a new PC.
But like it's stuck in customs.
It's been stuck in customs for two weeks now.
Bro, every day I wait and I was like, which one will be here?
And it's been stuck in customs for like...
Fucking Canada!
This is Canada's fault!
It's always Canada's fault!
God fucking damn it!
I could have had my new PC by now!
God damn it, Canada!
Anyway.
Yes.
Thank you for listening to...
Okay, let me fucking...
Where's my karaoke list?
Alright, here we go.
That was...
Slipping.
I can't believe I crashed.
Okay, we're just gonna expect crashes.
I don't wanna promise anything.
So like we're just...
I don't wanna be like...
Don't worry.
It's okay now because I...
I don't know.
It might not be okay.
So I don't promise anything yet.
Anyway, let me bring my piano over.
Boom.
I can't play piano by the way, but let me bring my piano over.
I don't know how to play the piano, but like let me bring my piano over here.
All my favorites still.
Okay, all these songs...
Okay, I'm...
I'm just not saying one of my favorites because technically all these songs are my favorite.
All of them are my favorites.
So there's no actually...
Like everything on here is one of my favorite songs.
So I need to stop saying one of my favorites.
All right.
I got my piano.
I'm singing this version because I don't like the original singer.
Okay, I like the original singer, but like I don't like...
I prefer this version more so than the original singer's version.
So you might know because I sang this before, but I still love it because I feel like the message is like really powerful.
I'm sorry.
No, I love it.
You can never know what it's like.
Your blood like winter freezes just like ice.
And there's a cold lonely night that shines from you.
You'll wind up like the wreck you hide behind that mask you use.
And did you think that thrill could never win?
Well, look at me.
I'm coming back again.
I got taste of love in a simple way.
And you need to know why I'm still sad and you just fade away.
I'm still standing, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
I'm still standing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Once I never could hope to win.
You staring down the road leaving me again.
The threats you made were meant to cut me down.
If our love was just a circus, you'd be a clown by now.
Don't you know I'm still standing better than I ever did.
Looking like a true survivor.
Feeling like a little kid.
And I'm still standing after all this time.
Picking up the pieces of my life without you on my mind.
I'm still standing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Pew pew pew pew pew pew.
Pretend that my piano can also do guitar solos.
Pew pew pew pew.
It's an electric piano.
Don't you know I'm still standing better than I ever did.
Looking like a true survivor.
Feeling like a little kid.
And I'm still standing.
After all this time.
Picking up the pieces of my life without you on my mind.
I'm still standing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Woooo!
Alright, for those who don't know what that song was, that was, uh, I'm still stand- I don't know.
For those who still don't know what that is, who would've known?
That was I'm Still Standing by Elton John, but also- but I didn't sing Elton John's version.
Cause I like the sing- the movie- movie sing version from Taron Egerton.
Um, who also played Elton John on his, like, biopic movie.
Uh, I honestly prefer his version so much more.
Um, especially in the sing one when he's a gorilla.
Uh, and it's- it's been one of my favorite songs, like, for a very long time.
So I am very happy to be able to sing this.
Anyway, let me chuck this piano out.
Thank you.
Thank you, piano.
I- I really appreciated piano for, uh, uh, for doing that.
Okay, I'm still standing.
I really appreciate the piano that I could totally play.
Chat.
The piano that I'm- I'm def- I definitely played, uh, uh, in front of all of you guys.
Alright, next song!
Next song.
Okay, ooh, okay.
This one is- this one's gonna be fun.
This one's gonna be fun.
You guys might enjoy this.
But, like, I need to time it- time- time the video.
This one also has a video chat.
So, you guys might enjoy this.
Let me...
Let me put this- let me find the song real quick.
Uh, I need to make sure it's the right version.
I need to time this- time this video as well.
But we're gonna move, guys.
We're gonna, uh...
We're gonna move to another- another setup real fast.
Guys, alright, all of you guys, out the concert hall.
Out the concert hall, everybody.
We're gonna go somewhere.
Alright, you guys all ready?
I know there's so many of you guys.
Out, out.
We're gonna move to another venue real quick.
But we'll come back.
We'll come back to this venue.
I just need you guys to all move out right now.
Alright, three, two, one.
Pew!
Alright.
Okay.
So, I need to make sure that, uh...
Alright, here we go.
I need to make sure I timed this correctly.
Alright, so, here's our new venue.
Don't worry.
There is a reason why we're in this venue.
Because the next song that we're singing requires a big- bigger venue.
Like, I need all this open space.
Uh...
I...
I really need all this open space for- for this particular venue.
And you're gonna realize when we're here.
But I need to make sure the video is timed correctly.
So, that is, like, the biggest issue.
So, let me...
Let me make sure this...
This video is timed perfectly.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
This should be it.
Alright, I hope this is correct.
I...
I hope...
I hope that I timed it correctly.
So, we're gonna see.
We're gonna...
Alright, here we go.
You're gonna realize what this song is the moment we play it.
Well, you Baba had them forty thieves.
Shattered hides and a thousand tails.
But, Master, you win luck cause of your sleeves.
You got a brand of magic that never fails.
You got some power in your corner now.
Some heavy ammunition in your cap.
You got some punch, pizzazz, yaku and howl.
See how you got yours, rub, blab, laugh.
And I'll say, Mr. Aladdin, sir.
What will your pleasure be?
Gonna take your order, jolt it down.
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Life is your restaurant.
And I'm your maitre d'.
Come on, whisper what it is you want.
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Ha!
Proud ourselves on service.
You're the boss, the king, the shah.
Say what you wish.
It's yours, true dish.
Wub a little more black, la-bah.
Have some of column A.
Try all of column B.
I'm in the mood to help you dig.
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Never had a friend like me.
Ha!
Ma-ha-ha!
Mo-na!
Na-ha-ha!
No, no.
Ma-ha-ha!
Na-ha!
Mm-ha-ha!
Can your friends do this?
Can your friends do that?
Do your friends pull this?
Of their little head?
Can your friends go poof?
Well, looky here.
Can your friends go abracadabra?
Let it rip!
And then make that sucker disappear!
So then, just sit there, slack-jawed, buddy-y-eyed.
I'm here to answer all your mid-day prayers.
You got me bona-fide, certified.
You got a genie for your shard affairs.
I got a powerful urge to help you out.
So what you wish you ever really want to know?
You got a list that's three miles long, no doubt.
Well, I know I deserve like so and all.
Mr. Alonzo, have a wish or two or three.
I'm on the job, you big nub-bob.
You ain't never had a friend, never had a friend, You ain't never had a friend, never had a friend, You ain't never...
Had a...
Friend...
Like...
Me!
Ha-ha!
Ha-ha-ha!
You ain't never had a friend like me.
Yes.
Uh...
Um...
That was also by shadd.
Ha-ha-ha!
A huge shoutout to shadd for this amazing video edit.
Um, I gave him some of the ideas to do.
You know, I used to do this all by myself manually.
But then I was like, why am I doing this all by myself manually when I can like actually have like..
You know.
When it can just play automatically for me instead of me pressing all these buttons.
I'm so excited.
But yes, huge shout out.
For those who don't know, it's never a friend like me from Aladdin, the 1992 version with Robin Williams.
Because, I'm sorry Will Smith but, you can never live up to Robin Williams' version, the original Genie.
So this was the original Robin Williams version of Friend Like Me.
It's also one of my favorite songs as well.
Yes, I don't like the live action movie songs.
There's some of them that's actually pretty decent.
But then there's so... the majority of them is pretty fucking shit.
Anyway guys, we're still gonna stay in this venue chat.
So don't worry.
You don't have to move chat.
We're all still in this venue.
So...
So do not worry chat.
You don't have to move.
We're all gonna be here.
Anyway, let me grab... alright the next song.
I feel like you sort of know what the next song is by a few things that I'm gonna put up my screen real quick.
Let me get rid of Friend Like Me.
Whoa, we're underwater now.
We're gonna swim.
Oh my god, are those fishes?
Oh my god, there's fishes now.
I hope that... I hope that...
I mean... it's sadly gonna be unarchived because it was so scuffed in the beginning.
I was crashing non-stop.
So sadly this is gonna be archived.
Guys, don't worry.
Dragoons can not breathe underwater.
But like, don't worry.
At least you get to watch this before you drown.
So...
Alright, so...
Are you guys ready for this song?
I'm gonna go in.
I didn't practice this song at all.
And to be fair, I'm gonna go in like...
I'm gonna go in from all the practice I've done as a little kid.
And I hope that...
I didn't practice this song at all recently.
And I'm just hoping that my fucking instinct is gonna kick in and remember this song.
Like...
But yes, has the volume been okay so far?
I hope it's not... instrumentals have not been too loud.
I hope the instrumentals have been okay and not too loud, chat.
Alright,
good.
Okay, here we go.
Yay!
Wait, before we start...
I need to... I need to hydrate.
I realize I haven't been really hydrating.
Hmm.
Okay, let me hydrate real...
Whoa!
Whoops.
At least that bottle of water was empty.
Hydrate, guys!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
I'm gonna hope that muscle memory kicks in here.
I added this last minute because I was like, I love this song.
We'll just do it like this for now.
Okay.
Here we go.
Yes!
I love this song.
Let's hear it.
Oh, my God.
Let's do it.
I said no.
That's it.
Take it from me!
Guess who's coming on that plate?
Uh oh!
Under the sea!
Nobody feed us, fry us and eat us in fricassee!
We what the land folks loves to cook!
Under the sea we off the hook!
We got no troubles, life is the bubbles!
Under the sea!
Since life is sweet here, we got the beat here naturally!
Even the surgeon and the ray, they get the urge to start to play!
We got the spirit, you got to hear it!
Under the sea!
The newt play the flute, the carp play the harp, the place play the bass and they sounding sharp!
The bass play the brass and the chub play the tub, the fluke is the duke of soul!
The ray he can play the lings on the string, the trout rocking out the blackfish he sings!
The smell and the sprite, they know where it's at!
And oh that bluebird!
The fish blow!
I hope you're not drowning in water now dragons!
Cause you can't breathe underwater!
Yeah!
Under the sea!
When the sardine begin to peaking, this music to me!
What do they say?
A lot of sand!
We got a hot Cretaceous!
And each little clam here, know how to jam here!
Under the sea!
Each little slug here, cutting a rug here!
Each little snail here, do you know how to wail here?
That's why it's hotter under the water!
Yeah we are lucky, down in the muck here!
Under the sea!
Woo!
Huge shout out to Little Doki for uh...
for fucking singing this song almost every day when she was a kid!
Well not that!
Huge shout out to Little Doki!
I didn't practice this song at all!
Um... today!
So like, huge shout out to Little Doki for like...
still fucking clutching it for me!
Cause I sang this song a lot!
Hahaha!
I was just like, oh my god!
Okay I'm gonna sing this!
I don't know how well I'm gonna do live!
But like... it can't be that bad!
Hahaha!
Alright!
Alright guys, we're gonna move venues!
Uh...
We're gonna move venues real quick!
But we're not gonna go back to the main venue yet chat!
So uh... give me a sec guys!
We're gonna be moving to another venue!
Everybody leave the ocean!
Leave... leave the ocean chat!
Leave!
We're gonna swim back up now!
Swim back up!
Hahaha!
Uh... dragoons!
Swim back up!
We need a...
We need to go out of the ocean to another venue!
Don't worry!
Time to download myself!
What do you mean by that?
Well...
Hahaha!
I've download...
DRAGOOONS!
I've turned into a TV!
Funniest shit ever!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Funniest fucking shit ever guys!
Hahaha!
Alright...
I'm gonna go straight in.
I practiced this song like twice!
Hahaha!
I think this is the right one, right?
Yeah, this is the right one!
Hahaha!
This was a triumph!
I'm making a note here!
Huge success!
It's hard to overstate my satisfaction!
Aperture Science!
We do what we must because we can!
For the good of all of us!
I swear.
I'm being so sincere... right now.
I swear I'm not angry.
But I got burned.
Think of all the things we've learned.
For the people who are still alive.
Hey, there's people still alive, guys.
Don't worry.
Go ahead and leave me.
I think I prefer to stay inside.
Maybe you'll find someone else to help you.
Maybe Black Mesa.
Ha!
That was a joke.
Ha ha!
Fat chance.
Anyway, this cake is great.
It's so delicious and moist.
Look at me still talking when there's science to do.
When I look out there, it makes me glad I'm not you.
I have experiments to run.
There is research to be done.
On the people who are still alive.
And believe me, I am still alive.
I'm doing science and I'm still alive.
I feel fantastic and I'm still alive.
While you're dying, I'll be still alive.
And when you're dead, I will be still alive.
Still alive.
Because I'm virtual.
I don't know if you know that.
Just so you guys know, I'm just, I'm virtual and that's why I'm still alive.
Anyway, you don't get the cake.
No, my immersion!
Donkey!
I'm jamming out!
No cake for you guys, sorry.
Because I'm the one that's still alive.
Alright guys, I'm gonna like, undownload myself from the TV now.
And for those who don't know, that song was Still Alive from Portal.
Um, uh, honestly, uh, I remember like listening to that song on repeat when I was like, a little, little dokey.
So I was like, you know what?
Let's do it.
Also like, I wanted to sing this for a while too.
But like, obviously like, Still Alive has like, a weird song.
Like, when it comes to, when it comes to like, perms and stuff.
So...
Yes, I downloaded a cake into the TV, so it's now mine.
So I'm glad I'm able to actually sing this song.
It was a little scuffed.
I mean, to be fair, this entire karaoke was a little scuffed.
But it's not about how well I sing, it's about how good it looks.
It's all about the visuals!
Not about how I sing!
Just look at how pretty everything looks!
As a...
Alright, time to go back to the venue guys!
Move along!
Back to the concert hall!
Back to the concert hall everybody!
Alright, we're back here.
I don't think I'm gonna update the list.
I'm getting lazier.
So we're gonna...
I'm getting a little lazier, so I'm just gonna get rid of the list right now.
Anyway guys, anyway.
This one is a classic too.
It's Christmas now.
Oh my god!
Do you know at this point with global warming, it might as well be...
It might as well be like...
It might as well...
It might as well still be snowing.
Okay, let me...
Let me see if I can pull this.
I don't know if it's actually in KaraFund.
So I'm gonna see if this is...
I know I sang this before.
So I'm like...
Is this...
Oh, it is!
Wait.
Is that...
Is that the right one?
Let me double check if this is the right one.
Hey.
Let me double check this.
I need to make sure.
This is one of my favorite.
Okay, all of them are my favorites.
Yeah!
Okay, it is.
Nice.
I love this.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, you guys ready?
Here we go.
Oh, I spoiled it.
I'm Mrs. White Christmas.
I'm Mrs. Snow.
I'm Mrs. Ice-cycle.
I'm Mrs. Temblow.
Friends call me Snow-Mizer.
Whatever I touch...
turns to snow in my clutch.
Oh I'm too much...
Oh, it's so cold.
That's me!
That's right!
That's a weird guy.
I said, but he's Mr. Timberlake.
Friends call me Snow-Mizer.
Whatever I touch, turns to snow in my clutch.
Oh, I'm too much.
I never want to know a day that's over 40 degrees.
I'd rather have it 30, 20, then 5, then let it freeze.
I'm Mrs. White Christmas.
I'm Mrs. Snow, that's right.
I'm Mrs. Icicle.
I'm Mrs. Timberlake.
Friends call me Snow-Mizer.
Whatever I touch, turns to snow in my clutch.
Too much.
Oh my god.
This song...
Okay, I have a feeling.
This is my favorite cover version of this song.
And it's from like...
It's like a female version of this.
And like she's so good at...
Like she sounds like Spinel from like that...
The...
That Steven Universe movie.
She sounds just like her.
And like she did like a female version cover of Snow-Mizer.
And that song's been stuck in my head ever since.
Huge shout out to her though.
Because she is actually so fucking talented.
And like she honestly like inspired...
Like...
Not inspired me, but like she actually like made me...
Made me like really like this song in general.
Because of the English cover of it.
I think if you look up female cover...
Snow-Mizer...
You might be able to find it.
Like it's sort of...
It has like...
Like I...
I'm basically sort of emulating her voice when I sing this.
Yeah.
Like when you hear the cover you're like...
Oh yeah, she's definitely trying to like emulate her voice.
Yes, this is...
This one was Snow-Mizer from something something...
The Year of Santa Claus.
The original version...
I don't like it as much.
To be fair.
I don't really like Heat-Mizer's song.
Heat-Mizer is like way too fucking slow for me.
So but like Snow-Mizer is really good.
Like I don't...
I don't know.
I never like thought much about the Snow-Mizer song.
Until like I heard the female cover of it.
And it was just so...
Um...
That is like...
That's why like it's...
I like remember it so well.
Um...
Because like the female cover was just so good.
Anyway...
Snowy stopped.
Everything melted.
It's...
No more snow.
Everything's gone now.
Snow has melted now for reals.
Alright what's the next song?
Snow-Mizer...
Ba da da da ba...
Ba ba da da ba...
He is too much.
Oh here we go.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's see.
Let me...
Put on an outfit real fast.
Alright.
Boop.
So I sort of like spoiled you guys a bit with this song.
I spoiled it earlier.
Um...
And you see that put back a...
Uh...
Certain goggles.
I put back like a certain goggles because there's a reason why.
And you'll...
You'll know why soon.
We'll just go straight in.
We're gonna go straight in.
I should've used the app instead of the actual fucking web program.
I think like that was the mistake I made.
That was the mistake I made for all the crashes.
Yeah.
I might...
Okay.
Warning.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fumble this a lot.
I only practiced a little bit for this.
But I really...
I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna try my best.
This appear as a moral dilemma.
Cause at first it was weird.
That I swore to eliminate the worst of the plague.
That devour humanity.
It's true.
I was vague on the house.
So how can it be that you have shown me the light.
It's a brand new day.
And the sun is high, all the birds are singing that you're gonna die.
How I hesitate, now I wonder why it's a brand new day.
All the times that you beat me, I'll cut yourself, forgive.
All the crimes that I've played, and it's honestly I'll live.
Mr. Cool, Mr. Right, Mr. Know-it-all is through.
Now my future is so bright, and I owe it all to you, who showed me the light.
It's a brand new day, I got no remorse.
Now the water's rising, but I know the course.
I'm gonna shock the world, gonna show bad horse.
It's a brand new day.
And Penny will see me, the evil in me.
Not a joke, not a dork, not a failure.
And she may cry, but her tears will dry, when I hand her the keys to a shine.
It's a brand new Australia.
It's a brand new day, yeah the sun is high.
All the angels sing, because you're gonna die.
Go ahead and laugh, yeah I'm a funny guy.
So everyone goodbye.
It's a brand new day.
Yeah, it's also Dr. Horrible!
So the reason why I have a city behind me is that like, um, it's called Brand New Day from, also from Dr. Horrible's sing-along blog.
And then, um, the reason why I have a city behind me is that in the music video, he's in like, in his dreams, he turns like 50 feet tall, and he starts like fucking being Godzilla and like crushing all the city, the city around him.
So that, this is me.
Pretend I'm like, like 100 feet tall right now, stomping through the city.
And like, pushing everything down.
Just like the music video.
Yeah, I'm like a kaiju right now.
This is kaiju doki at the moment.
Like,
But, but that is like the ending of the fucking song.
That's why, that's why there's a city behind me.
If you're a Dr. Horrible sing-along blog fellow fan, you would...
You would, you would recognize the, um, the reference.
Majority of visuals are just like, you know, things that you can like, you recognize.
You're like, oh my god, that was in the video, you know?
You're like, oh my god, I know this, this was in the video.
Okay.
Um, the next song, let me hydrate real fast.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
You can tell I haven't sang in a long time.
That's cause I'm so bad.
You can tell.
Um, you can tell that, uh...
I'm not very good at singing cause, uh, I'm compensating right now.
Um, alright.
I'm fumbling a lot.
Cause I'm super nervous and like, when I was like crashing a lot, I like, the crashes actually, uh, fuck with my groove.
It actually messed my groove up.
Alright, anyway.
Um, we're gonna move venue.
Sorry I'm kicking you guys out again.
Uh, I'm gonna, I'm gonna kick you guys out again.
Uh, cause we're gonna be moving to a new venue.
Uh, you might recognize this background.
Uh, this place that I'm bringing you to.
Uh, alright, give me a sec.
Woo!
Alright, you guys recognize that?
Hahaha.
Another venue change, chat.
Another, um, another, another venue change.
Uh, you guys might recognize this.
Hahaha.
Okay, I hope that I timed this okay.
Like...
Hahaha.
Alright, let's try this.
Okay, this is...
Um, we all thought the other stuff was scuffed.
This might be very scuffed.
Okay, I just don't know if I can time this correctly.
Okay.
Welcome to the internet.
Have a look around.
Anything that brain of yours can think of can be found.
Oh wait, you guys can't hear it!
Already scuffed.
Hahaha.
I just realized you can't even hear it.
Sorry.
We'll try again soon.
Round two.
Hahaha.
I almost acapella-ed it.
Oh no.
Instrumentals are supposed to hide my flaws.
Um.
Hahaha.
I realized last minute I almost acapella-ed.
Alright, here we go.
Welcome to the internet.
Have a look around.
Anything that brain of yours can think of can be found.
We've got mountains of content.
Some better, some worse.
If none of it's of interest to you, you'd be the first.
Welcome to the internet.
Come and take a seat.
Would you like to see the news or any famous women's feet?
There's no need to panic.
This isn't a test.
Just nod or shake your head and we'll do the rest.
Welcome to the internet.
What would you prefer?
Would you like to fight for civil rights or tweet a racial slur?
Be happy!
Be horny!
Be bursting with rage!
We've got a million different ways to engage.
Welcome to the internet.
Put your cares aside.
Here's a tip for straining pasta.
Here's a nine year old who died.
We've got movies and doctors and fantasy sports.
And a bunch of colored pencil drawings of all the different characters in like, I don't know, fucking each other.
Welcome to the internet.
Hold on to your socks.
Cause a random guy just kindly sent you photos of his cock.
They are grainy and not pudding.
He just sent you more.
Don't act surprised.
You know you like it, you whore.
See a man beheaded.
Get offended.
See a string.
Show us pictures of your children.
Tell us every thought you think.
Shout a rumor by a broom source and a deathly.
Shout a rumor to a boomer.
Or DM a girl and groomer.
Do a zoom or find a tumor in you.
Here's a healthy breakfast option.
You should kill your mom.
Here's why women never fuck you.
Here's how you can build a bomb.
Which Power Ranger are you?
Take this quirky quiz.
Obama sent the immigrants to vaccinate your kids.
Could I interest you in everything all of the time?
A little bit of everything all of the time.
Apopie is a tragedy and boredom is a crime.
Anything and everything all of the time.
Could I interest you in everything all of the time?
A little bit of everything all of the time.
Apopie is a tragedy and boredom is a crime.
Anything and everything all of the time.
I love Bo-Bram.
You know...
It wasn't always like this.
I used to play Neopets.
Very long ago.
Just before your time.
Right before the towers fell.
Circa 99.
This was catalogs.
Travel blogs.
Chat room or two.
Set our sights.
Spend our nights.
Waiting.
For you.
Yeah, you!
Unshakable you.
Mommy let you use her iPad.
You were barely two, man.
It did all the things...
we designed it to do.
Look at you.
You.
Unstoppable.
Watchable.
Your time is now.
Your insides out.
Honey.
How you grew.
And if we stick together.
Who knows what we'll do.
It was always the plan.
To put that world in your hand.
Could I interest you in everything all of the time?
A bit of everything all of the time.
A little pause... and we are back.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize how fast the beginning was.
I forgot how fast the beginning was.
I'm stumbling.
My lips are stumbling.
But yes, welcome to the internet.
From Bo Burham.
I've always hesitated to sing this song because Bo Burham was like, you know, the song was like, you know, very, very, you know, there's a lot in there in that song.
But I was like, you know what?
You know what?
I'm going to sing it.
I was like, fuck it.
I'm going to fucking sing this song.
I don't care anymore.
I want to...
I remember when it first came out, I was like, jeez, I had that song on.
I was like, I'm going to fucking sing this song on repeat.
And it was like, it was honestly, it's so good.
It's such a really good song.
Even though, even though like, you know, the lyrics in there is a little, whoa.
The lyrics is like, whoa.
But like, it's, you know, you can't deny it.
It's a fucking earworm.
Like it gets stuck in your head.
And the parodies are also really, really, really fucking good.
Anyway, I am kicking guys out of here.
This is actually somebody's room that broke in.
So I'm going to kick you guys out because we got to...
We don't live here.
We got to go back to the concert hall, guys.
We got to go back.
So back to the concert hall we go.
You're back here again.
I know it's a lot of work, like moving you guys back and forth a lot.
But here we are again.
Here we are.
So this one, this one.
This one.
We're just going to like listen to...
Honestly, it's just going to be like...
You hear the backing vocals?
Because I thought it was really funny when I sang the song.
But there's no actual...
There's no actual like...
How do I say?
There's no actual like karaoke of it.
So we're just going to sing it because I thought it was really funny.
I thought it was really good.
So I was like, you know, we're going to sing it without the...
What about the...
There's no karaoke.
So like I thought it would be a good time to sing this.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, you guys heard it.
Like who...
Let me see.
I need to find the lyrics version so I know how to sing it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, so the reason why is because I thought the song really fits me really well.
Hahaha.
To be fair, this is like the most scuffed way.
This is actually sort of like...
The rest after that I haven't...
The other songs after this I was just like...
I'm not like prepared.
There's no like sets for anything for it.
But I just want...
After this song...
Actually no.
After the Welcome to the Internet songs after that there's actually no...
No like sets or props for the songs after that.
But I just want to...
But...
So like you could take Welcome to the Internet as like the finale.
But we're still going on.
We're gonna still go on.
Hahaha.
Okay, let me double check this.
Okay, okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, you guys ready?
You guys ready chat?
Alright, here we go.
Hahaha.
If I fumble at least like...
You know, the actual singers will sing the song for me.
Hahaha.
Okay, here we go.
We're doing a sequel.
We're back by popular demand.
Come on everybody.
Strike up a band.
We're doing a sequel.
That's what we're doing.
V-tubing.
And everybody knows the sequel's never quite as good.
Hahaha.
Friends, this is it.
Do it all again.
Hahaha.
Until the credits roll.
We got another goal to show that we can do it all again.
Hahaha.
Doing a sequel.
There's no need to disguise.
The studio considers us a viable group.
Really?
We're doing a sequel?
The Dragoons once more.
They wait for Tom Hanks to make Toy Story 4.
Wooo!
That's the end.
But no my friends.
This is when we do it all again.
Do it all again.
Hahaha.
Let's give it a shot.
Oh I mean now is a happy Simplot.
Oh it's about getting the Muppets back together again.
Oh my god.
Getting Doki Bird back together.
Her skin is four years old.
But we're doing it.
And they have to kiss each other.
Huh?
Kermit, how about the Muppets go on a world tour?
Doki goes on a world tour?
Hahaha.
My friends, this is it.
We get to do it all again.
Hahaha.
Until the credits roll.
We got another goal to show that we can do it all again.
The Doki World Tour.
The Muppets again.
It's the Doki again.
It's the Doki.
Again.
Okay.
It just stopped there.
Hahaha.
I really wanted to sing this song.
Even though I had no karaoke.
I really wanted to sing.
Hahaha.
It's an abrupt cut.
I really wanted to sing it because I was like...
This feels so me.
The Doki World Tour.
Hahaha.
It actually just stops there.
I was like, wait what?
Hahaha.
I was so surprised.
I thought there would be more.
But I guess this was the movie version.
I got the movie version by the way.
Hahaha.
I was like, this must be the right video.
I think.
Because it's like...
But there's actually a 4 minute video.
But I was like, you know what?
The short version is good enough.
The short version is good enough for us.
But we're doing a sequel from the Muppets.
And I was like, oh my god.
This relates to me.
Hahaha.
This relates to me so hard.
So I was like, we're gonna...
We're gonna do it all again guys.
We're gonna do it all again.
Alright.
Let me pull up...
I wrote some other songs that I wanted to do.
Like as a bonus.
For all you guys.
But I need to find it.
I need to find my list.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, let's see.
Let's see.
I have 3 bonus songs.
I have 3 bonus songs for you guys.
I don't have a set for this.
But I'm willing to do it for you guys.
Let's see.
Ah...
Alright, here we go.
I've always liked this song.
I mean, I love all the songs.
Hahaha.
I love all of them.
That's the secret.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Nope.
Good thing you guys didn't hear that.
Alright, here we go.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Okay.
Guys, you ready?
Alright.
So...
The only way to get what you want...
Is to become...
A human yourself.
Hahaha.
My dear...
Sweet child.
That's what I do.
It's what I live for.
To help unfortunate dragoons...
Like yourself.
Poor souls...
With no one else to turn to.
Hahaha.
I admit that in the past...
I've been a nasty.
They weren't kidding when they called me...
Well, a witch.
But you'll find that nowadays...
I've mended all my ways.
Repent to seeing the light and made a switch.
True?
Yes.
But I fortunately know a little magic.
It's a talent that I've always had possessed.
And dear lady, please don't laugh.
I use it on behalf of the miserable, lonely, and depressed.
Pathetic.
Hahaha.
Poor unfortunate souls.
In pain.
In need.
This one's long and hard.
And wanting to be thinner.
That one wants to get the girl.
And do I help them?
Yes indeed.
Those poor unfortunate souls.
So sad.
So true.
They come flocking to my cauldron crying...
Spounds are so pleased.
And I help them.
Yes I do.
It's happened once or twice.
Someone couldn't pay the price.
And I'm afraid I had to rake and cross the coals.
Yes I've had the odd complaint.
But I've been a saint.
To those poor unfortunate souls.
Hahaha.
Have we got a deal, dragons?
I've become human.
I'll never be with my father and sisters again.
But you'll have your doki.
Hahaha.
Life's full of tough choices, isn't it?
Oh.
And there is one more thing.
Hmm.
We haven't discussed the subject of...
Payment.
I'm not asking much.
Just a token really.
An akasupa.
What I want from you is...
Your voice.
Hahaha.
You'll have your looks.
Your pretty beak.
And don't underestimate the importance of...
Body language.
Hahaha.
The men up there don't like a lot of blabber.
They think a girl is pretty.
But the one who gossips is a bore.
Yes, some Latin is pretty preferred.
For ladies not to say a word.
And after all, dear, what is Ido Prado for?
Come on, they're not that impressed with conversation.
True gentlemen avoid it when they can.
But they don't ensuin and fawn on a lady who's withdrawn.
It's she who holds her tongue who gets a man.
Come on, you poor unfortunate soul.
Go ahead.
Make your choice.
I'm a very busy woman.
I haven't got all day.
It won't cost much.
Just your voice.
You poor unfortunate soul.
It's sad, but true.
If you want to cross the bridge, my sweet, you've got to pay the toll.
Take a gulp and take a breath, and go ahead and sign the scroll.
Flotsam, Jetsam, now I've got it, boys.
The boss is on a roll.
This poor unfortunate soul.
Hahaha.
Baluga saruga cum winds of the Caspian Seas.
La rinse glas... dis is Latin I cannot say.
La voce to me!
Now superchat.
Guess more!
Keep superchatting!
Yay!
Thank you.
That is the longest fucking outro.
I forgot.
Thank you for all the superchats everybody.
Oh my god did I got Jesus Christ?
Thank you Jesus for the superchat.
Thank you.
I forgot how long the outro was for this fucking song.
Oh my god.
Alright do we end it with another... do we do another Disney song?
You know I'll do an encore.
Of a song we did before for the ending.
But let me... let me do... let's see.
We'll do this.
Oh my gosh so that's what fell.
I was like what the fuck fell and it was my... it was my... it was my stream deck.
Alright.
Oh my god free superchat!
David thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you thank you!
Alright.
You know let me...
Alright we'll do this one.
I actually do have props for this.
So give me a sec.
Let me...
Actually I don't.
I don't know where it is.
I didn't prepare this prop but because this is a bonus song.
But this is another Disney song.
I'll sing another Disney song for all you guys.
And it will end it with a encore of a song I did before.
I forgot to hydrate.
You might recognize this because it's on my channel.
It's also one of the easiest Disney songs out there so there's no way I can fuck it up right?
Hello.
Pa
-pam -pa-dum pa-pam-pa-dum.
Look for the fair necessities.
The simple fair necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
That's right.
I mean the fair necessities.
Old mother nature's recipes.
That bring the fair necessities of life.
Wherever I wonder.
Wherever I roam.
I couldn't be fonder.
Of my big home.
The bees are buzzing in the trees.
To make some honey just for me.
When you look under the rocks and plants.
And take a glance at the fancy ants and me.
Try a few.
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Look for the fair necessities.
The simple fair necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
That's right.
I mean the fair necessities.
The bare necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease.
With just the bare necessities of life.
Now when you pick a paw paw.
Or a prickly pear.
And you prick a raw paw.
Well next time.
Beware.
Don't pick that prickly pear by the paw.
When you pick a pear try to use the claw.
But you don't need to use the claw.
When you pick a pair of the big paw paw.
Uh huh.
Have I given you a clue?
Hmm?
You understand?
The bare necessities of life will come to you.
Will come to you.
Alright, pretend I have a trumpet solo.
I have a trumpet right now.
Oh wait, I know!
My piano trumpet!
Pretend my piano is playing the trumpet.
Pew pew pew.
It's like those electric pianos.
Oh my god, now I'm doing margaritas on my electric piano!
Woo!
A piano!
It's good!
Yeah!
Woo!
Look at my fingers go on the piano!
Ba da ba da ba ba ba ba ba boo!
How does she do it?
On the electric piano!
Chucked it off.
Ah man, that was really living.
So just try and relax.
Yeah.
Cool it.
Fall apart in my backyard.
Cuz let me tell you something little britches, When you act like that bees act, Uh-uh-uh!
You're working too hard!
And don't spend your time looking around...
For something you want.
That can't be found.
When you find out you can live without it and go along not thinking about it, I'll tell you something true.
The bear necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Yeah!
Look for the bear necessities.
The simple bear necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
Damn right!
I mean the bear necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease.
With just the bear necessities of life.
Yeah man!
Woo!
Did you know this is the easiest Disney song out there in the world?
There's no way I could fuck it up.
It's literally the one of the easiest Disney songs out there.
Praise for bear necessities.
Yeah!
It's literally the easiest one.
Out of all the Disney songs out there, if you look it up, the bear necessities is the easiest because it has like a very small vocal range.
Like it's like the vocals for it is like super simple.
And...
And thank God because like I'm not like a gifted singer.
Anyway!
Last song chat.
We made it to the...
We're doing an encore of a song that I've done before.
And I think you guys want me to do this again.
I'm pretty sure.
So...
So we'll do the last...
The very last song.
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure I time this correctly.
Because like that is the worst part.
It's just timing.
Alright.
Let me make sure I time this correctly.
We're gonna move the venue.
Guys, this is the last song.
We're gonna do an encore of a song we've done before.
But we're gonna move venues.
You guys will... You guys love this place.
Hahaha.
Anyway, let's start up the Dragoon PTA meeting again guys.
Guys, OK.
I feel like I have to reiterate about regarding this issue that we have.
That has cursed this foking stream in the beginning.
Um...
Hahaha!
New meeting!
New Dragoon PTA meeting!
Hahaha!
I have a new new dragoon PTA meeting chat.
All right, you see some issues that we have I have to redo this meeting because like nothing has really been fixed, but anyway, let's go I
Need any blame something Sorry restart this Fuckin Canada!
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me restart guys new dragoon PTA meeting guys.
New dragoon PTA meeting.
Here we go now I'm ready
Times have changed our kids are getting worse.
They won't obey their parents.
They just want to fight and curse Should we blame the government or blame society?
No!
Blame Canada!
With all their beady little eyes and flapping heads so full of lies Blame Canada!
We need to form a full assault.
It's Canada's fault!
Don't blame me for my son dragoon had
my picture on his shelf.
No SCM tells me to fuck myself Well blame Canada!
Blame Canada!
Oh wait, this is acapella.
They're not even a real country anyway My son could've been a doctor or a lawyer rich and true But instead he burned up like a piggy on a BBQ
This is Canada's fault.
Heck no!
Blame Canada!
With all their hawky hollaboo and that bitch dokie bird 2 blame Canada!
Shame on Canada!
The slut who was head the trash must match laughter and fun must all be undone must blame them that cause a fuss for someone things will blaming oooooooooooossss.
Fucking Canada's fault.
Of course Kanda ruined my encore.
I did acapella.
God fucking dammit Kanda.
Kanda made me do an acapella.
We're doing this again.
I refuse to do this whole song in acapella.
Encore of an encore.
Fucking Kanda man.
It's okay.
Guys, this is gonna be unarchived by the way.
This is way too scuffed.
We're unarchiving this.
Don't worry.
Round 2.
Another PTA meeting.
Times have changed.
Our kids are getting worse.
They won't obey their parents.
They just wanna fight and curse.
Should we blame the government?
Or blame society?
Or should we blame...
No, of course not.
No!
Blame Kanda.
With all their beady little eyes and flapping heads so full of lies.
In the form of a song it's Kanda's fault.
They ruined my stream.
Bro.
Saw the entire cartoon and now he's off to join the clan.
And my boy Dragon once had a picture on his shelf.
But now I see him tells me to fuck myself.
Blame Kanda.
It seems that everything's gone wrong since Kanda came along.
They're not even a real country anyway.
My son could've been a doctor or a lawyer rich and true.
Instead he'd burn up like a piggy on a barbecue.
Should we blame the matches?
Should we blame the fire?
Or the doctors who will allow him to inspire?
No!
Blame Kanda!
They ruined my stream!
It's for karaoke!
Blame Kanda!
The smoke was cut, the trash was smashed, the laughter and fun must all be a done.
We must blame them and cause a fuss before someone thinks of blaming us!
Alright, I'm done.
I'm done blaming Kanda.
Sorry, this is like four times I sang this song.
Like, I fucking feel it.
Hahaha!
God fucking dammit, Kanda!
I sang this song four times.
That's how pissed off I am.
I can't believe I sang this acapella.
I had to tell the world of how much Kanda has forsaken me.
And my Canadian... fucking Canadian customs!
And Canadian ISP!
Hahaha!
Fucking KANADA!
Anyway, back to the concert hall.
Hahaha!
Where is my PC?
Alright, Riverbob.
Alright, anyway.
Um, I hope you guys enjoyed.
Um, okay.
Okay, okay guys.
The reason why I don't want to archive this is because it was so fucking scuffed from the beginning.
Um, when I could have just like honestly used the program...
KaraFun program.
Instead of like the...
Um, instead of like the web version.
And it was the web version that was causing all my crashes.
And the moment I swapped...
Um...
The moment I...
I swapped like...
Uh...
Hahaha!
To...
To like the...
The actual...
Um...
The...
The program...
The program is stopped crashing.
And I'm like, no!
I wish I had done that in the beginning!
Hahaha!
Then we would have been scuffed!
We would have been crashing!
No!
Hahaha!
I'm a coward though!
I'm a coward!
Hahaha!
And I'm a coward!
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Convince me to archive this.
Alright.
Hahaha!
Thanks for scuff and mix it.
Ah!
I'm just embarrassed!
I'm such a perfectionist!
Because I worked so hard!
I worked so hard planning all of this!
So I was like...
That's why I was like so sad!
I planned...
Like I worked so hard trying to plan all of this and doing all the assets and everything.
So I was like so embarrassed when I started crashing.
Hahaha!
Ah!
Are you guys sure?
Are you guys sure I should archive this?
Okay.
I'll...
For you guys, draggoons.
I'm so embarrassed.
But for you guys, I'll archive.
I'll keep this archived.
I'll keep it archived.
I'm so embarrassed.
Oh my god.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Okay, everybody.
Um...
Thank you, everyone.
I...
I hope you guys enjoyed.
I'll do an after party.
But because I put it at 7.30, I didn't think I'd be like streaming longer.
But like I'm gonna delay it a little.
I'm gonna push the after party like maybe like 20 minutes more.
So I can like chill a little bit.
Hahaha!
But like a huge shoutout to Shad for doing...
Editing all of the...
Editing all the...
The videos for it.
I definitely want my next karaoke.
I want to make it like bigger and like more professional.
Less...
Less scuffed.
As this time, I want to do it less scuffed.
Hahaha!
I'll definitely be much more prepared.
I feel like I definitely could have worked on this karaoke a lot more.
I feel like I definitely could have worked on it a lot more.
Um...
And gave myself more time.
But it was definitely harder to balance everything that was going on.
And I definitely could have practiced the songs a lot more.
Um...
But next time, I'll make sure it's even.
Alright, guys.
At...
What?
How many subscribers am I on right now?
How many subscribers am I on?
At...
Uh...
At 800k?
At 800k subscribers will be my next karaoke.
And...
But that next karaoke will be bigger, better, more production value.
And I would have practiced much more.
Hahaha!
I promise all you guys.
I would practice a lot more.
Um...
For...
It's...
800k.
Bigger production.
A lot more practice.
Less scuff.
And we'll have a better PC at 800k.
We get to 800k subscribers.
Like...
Huge production value.
Hahaha!
More production value than the trumpet piano?
Bro, it's gonna be bigger and better than the fucking trumpet piano.
I swear, guys.
Hahaha!
That's when you know it's more extreme than...
No way!
Um...
But yes, I'm gonna call it...
I'm gonna end the karaoke here.
I'll raid the...
I'm gonna push the after party waiting room to like 20 minutes.
20 minutes to just chill a little bit.
And reset myself.
But thank you everybody for coming to my first karaoke!
I'm sorry it's pretty scuffed and I was crashing in the beginning.
I'm sorry for crashing a lot in the beginning.
Hahaha!
But it got better.
Guys!
It got...
It stopped crashing at least!
Thank God!
But yes, thank you.
I really did enjoy myself.
I had a lot of fun with all you guys and I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
Um, I really did have like a lot of fun doing this karaoke for all you guys.
Uh, yes.
I'll see you guys very, very, very soon!
Bye everybody!
Bye!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop!